[Door creaking]
- Hello?
Is someone there?
- Uh, you're at a...
darkness retreat?
- What the hell is a darkness retreat?
He'll never—
- Shh.
- Ah, yes! A darkness retreat!
And you must be my conscience.
- ...Yes.
I love player empowerment,
but this season, Aaron got maybe
TOO empowered.
- So as punishment,
we're brainwashing—no,
strongly suggesting...
that he join the Jets.
No offense.
- No offense is literally our problem.
- Fine! I'm going to the Jets.
So long as...
- He wants us to sign the ghost of
Jordy Nelson,
get McAfee hired at WFAN,
gift him that Joe Namath jacket...
- Much like my personal hero,
Scarlet Witch
after she turns evil,
I have eliminated all player autonomy
and
trapped them in a Gridiron Heights
of my own making.
I mean...
we renovated.
- [Producer:] Isn't that just the same Gridiron Heights
but with a monorail?
- What?! No!
It's a new day in Gridiron Heights.
We're restructuring
with some old favorites
in exciting new places.
- Just win, baby.
The tuck rule was a fumble.
Josh McDaniels is a football genius.
- Oh, and you're gonna love
the direction we take Derek Carr
in this season.
- I'm fixin' to get me some etouffee
down there by the Quarter, now.
- Some players were easier to
reprogram—I mean convince—than others!
- Um, Jalen,
some people were talking shit
saying you'll never play for the Dolphins?
- MAN! I'LL SHOW THEM.
- Before long, we'll have the
Gridiron Heights
I've always dreamed of,
with exciting new characters!
- Hmmm,
I think I could mold you.
- Some characters will have to be...
retired.
- Goodnight, Ezekiel.
I loved you the very most.
- But I didn't retire.
You can just re-sign me!
- I'm happy we got to an agreement.
- Gridiron Heights:
It's normal,
good and free of scandal.
- YOU CAN'T MAKE ME SELL!
- TEAMY DISTANCING HIMSELF
FROM SNYDER!
RAWR!!!
[Crashing]
- This is your fault for not having an agent.
- They said they're sending me to a team upstate
where I'll have
plenty of room to scramble!
- They'll be back for us any minute now.
Annnnnny minute.
- Baltimore's gonna come a-calling,
just you wait.
- Nexts years my year.
- I could make a comeback.
- I'm Ryan Leaf. Get me out of here.